hello everybody how's everybody doing
hope you're doing fine and today we have
another exciting day we're gonna start
with just a review of the extinction
issue okay and I just wanted to mention
that there were a couple issues there
you know one was the homework nobody did
it which may mean many things could be
that interested or you don't have a
proposal or or you're still thinking
you're still coming up with stuff and
the homework consisted essentially in
coming up with an alternative mechanism
for killing man killing our species
making it go extinct by way of
starvation through the food chain okay
so far as far as I know there are two
proposals on the table one is from this
fellow guy McPherson P says it's gonna
be the climate yeah the ones that when
I'm proposing and that's that the
economy is going to fall apart where do
I get this well when you do extinction
101 you go back in time you find out
that the past species does that
disappear that mass extinctions did so
through the food chain and so I think
food is the issue I think that's the
that's economics for the animals that's
the resource that they that wild animal
manages and so there's no reason to
think that if all animals in the Permian
in the Triassic and the Jurassic and the
Cretaceous all of them disappeared when
they disappeared in a mass extinction
they disappeared because of food there's
no reason to think that man is gonna
disappear in any other way
therefore we don't have to worry about
you know looking through the telescope
to see if a comet comes down or an
asteroid we don't have to look through
the microscope to see if a bug is going
to
we don't have to worry about as far as
I'm concerned climate change the only
thing we have to worry about is food
and yeah when you look at that if you
take away food from man I think he's
gonna die right I don't how long can you
last without food maybe a month two
months and and yeah if our global
economy falls apart then we lose food so
I do have a reason I do have a mechanism
okay and that's the reason I'm putting
this challenge this homework for whoever
wants to pick it up you know the glove
is in your face and you got to do
extinction 101 before you do extinction
102 102 is man 101 is extinction first
you need to explain extinction okay what
the mechanism of extinction for past
species was and hopefully you don't come
up with what the establishment has come
up with you know asteroids and volcanoes
and supernovas and all this other
nonsense the other thing is you may have
a different theory for the extinction of
man hey I'd love to hear it so you know
don't tell me how men is not gonna die
tell me how he is gonna die give me a
mechanism okay okay anyways uh talking
about the end of time at least for man
today is a time day we're gonna talk
about time and a good place to start is
in the history of time I'm just gonna
give a very brief history okay just a
big whoa we're not a focus there all
right hello I'm back my Tesla so what's
the deal with the history of time well
just in general terms right keep going
out of focus I don't know why camera
doesn't like me I guess today well if I
go out of focus I'll keep talking we
have an issue with time in that we
started a long time ago doing calendars
and these calendars essentially there
were all kinds of calendars out there
they reflected essentially the the
farming world the sowing season
harvesting you know the seasons they
realized something changed throughout
the year and eventually they figured out
you know you know that we either the Sun
was going around us or we were going
around the Sun something was moving out
there
there was nothing standing still we
didn't have moon calendars a lot of
cultures used moon calendars the Greeks
had eight and nine day weeks you know so
we don't we didn't always have seven day
weeks and the other thing with the
Greeks is they set the calendars also
like every four years they had the
Olympics and they set the calendars to
the Olympics also well Julius Caesar
finally put a calendar that replaced the
earlier Roman calendar and he put 365
days in their calendar I think that was
already there but he changed the the the
starting point of the calendar
essentially and it was his son his
adopted son which was his nephew
Augustus Octavius and Augustus and later
changed the calendar to reflect Julia
Jules for July and August for August see
you wonder why September is it's the
ninth month when Sept is a seven
why October is the eighth month when
means eight right and why it's the tenth
month and so on well they moved all
September October November and December
which were seven eight seven eight nine
and ten they moved them to nine ten
eleven twelve and in between they put
seven and eight which were July for
Julius Caesar and August for Augustus
Caesar Pope Gregory would change it many
years later there were some little
issues there and so they amended that
and what's interesting is that the
minutes and seconds you know they really
didn't become important until the end of
the 17th century because until that time
they had no way of measuring
such fine points at least a second and
so these came into being at the end of
the 17th century and so for this you got
a kind of look at a parallel between
time and also the evolution of clocks
and so here's a little history of clocks
okay just a quick rundown
we started with Sun dials and water
clocks and they look something like this
you can see by looking at the type of
clocks that we had in antiquity you can
see how we measure time in the old days
the first one down there is uh in Napa
Playa Nubia in Egypt they say it's
anywhere from six thousand to maybe
seven thousand five hundred years ago
before Christ and and these were stones
and essentially it's a sundial but it's
for the seasons and then you have the
typical sundial that was used quite a
bit in the old days and that one's in
Tarragona in Spain the one that's in the
center then you had the Egyptian water
clock the clip Sidra as the greeks
called it and they would measure how
many essentially when when the bucket
was empty the the funnel there was empty
then you have maybe fifteen minutes were
up because they would drip at a certain
pace and they also had different types
of here's another type of clock actually
not a clock but it's a seasonal type of
clock okay so keep that in mind which is
the Kukulkan serpent in the in Chichen
Itza and when the Sun just you can see
the Sun just making a shadow there or
thinning it and that was a serpent there
at the bottom you can see the head of
the serpent and so that would tell when
the equinox was around you also had
cattle clocks yeah you know and this was
used quite a bit in the old days after
you know
you're talking about in the ad area
right not in the BC the Arabs use that
quite a bit and it looks something like
what you see on the right you they had
different markings sometimes on the wall
or behind it or whatever and as the
candle burned well you knew that one
hour went by two hours went by and so on
so these were our our first attempts at
creating clocks and obviously you know
with those you cannot measure seconds
and minutes that accurately so it was
usually some of these were used like the
Sun dials they were used to check how
many hours a laborer now a slave worked
or whatever you know and so they would
mark it and then they would know more or
less how many hours went by or whatever
measure they had at the time with a
sundial so it was a very crude system
but it worked for many centuries and we
forget that you know people in the old
days they did not have a wristwatches
and they didn't keep track of time as
carefully as we do today time has become
more and more important over time okay
then we started with mechanical clocks
in the 14th century and here you get a
couple ideas of what a mechanical clock
looked like they were a little bit
cumbersome they had these weights and
gears they moved around they worked but
you know they were they were usually put
in churches and so on so other people to
get an idea what time it was in in the
day but it's not like you carry one of
these on your wrist around you know
wristwatch with all those gears yeah so
we had to improve the clocks before we
could start timing things more
accurately and one of the first guys to
come up with stuff was Galileo and he
came up with a pendulum clock yeah he
designed it
that's his design in the center and a
modern version of it on the right and
what it was is again gears and all but
this time it
is run by a pendulum okay and he
designed it he didn't ever built it
guess his son try to build it but never
finished it the guy who's gonna finish
one of these pendulum clocks is
christiaan huygens he's gonna build his
first one 16:56 and then he built more
sophisticated ones that one on the lower
right is from 1673 okay
so he started working on that he also he
also was a good at trying to figure out
you know how to how to be able to carry
a clock on a ship because one of the big
problems they had throughout the
sixteenth seventeenth century up to the
18th century was longitude you know they
could figure out the longitude they
could figure out the latitude with a Sun
you know the Sun was straight over a
head you know it was 12:00 noon but you
didn't know how far you know you were
along longitudinal lines you know and
and so they one of the fellows who tried
to fix that problem was Christian
Huygens he he had his chronometer a
little device that he made but it was
not very accurate so it was never
accepted by the British but the British
or Americans was from Netherlands and he
was sponsored by the King of France
Louis the fourteenth but the British
picked up on that and said hey you know
maybe we can figure out a way to to
calculate longitude and they put out a
little reward there for anyone to come
up with with something and one guy did
and and that was this fellow Harrison
John Harrison he comes up with marine
chronometer okay and again this was the
problem the problem is is of ship sailed
say west they could tell you know where
the Sun was at that point if it was
right overhead but they could not tell
you the longitude
and for that they had to have accurate
clocks that would tell you how far you
ventured from from light from England
right and so clocks became more and more
sophisticated over time well you know
again time followed clocks more or less
they were parallel the problem comes
really in the 19th century when we
started doing some weird things with
time and forget about clocks now now we
get into time and and some of the
fellows have balled with this revolution
because it's the you could call it the
time revolution comes at the end of the
19th century and it's a result of this
ether okay they were trying to show they
were trying to figure out how light goes
through the ether time and figure out
what it really was was it the waving of
the ether and so on well in 1987
Michelson and Morley run their
interferometer tests and they show that
there is no ether at least to the
majority of people in those days that's
what they concluded from their
experiments and this shocked a lot of
people and because they said no how can
it be if there's no ether what is it
that's waving and to this day we have an
answer that question right they don't
know the mathematicians don't know
because they never figured out you know
they're only doing calculations they
never deal with objects and that's
that's the main problem there but so
what happened well and what happened was
you had this group of people who these
celebrities okay and these are the
people who were gonna start the
revolution I'm just naming a few of them
here there were others okay what is
George did Sarah who is the first one
who picks up on the michelson-morley
experiment he doesn't like the results
and he says and he starts them proposing
that maybe lengths contracted you know
that maybe the interferometers were
squashed in the direction of travel and
well I don't know a lot of people
laughed at him but then Hendrik Lorentz
who who was also quite popular in those
days he
up on that idea developed his equation
in which he shows that it all has to do
with the velocity of object of the
object in relation to the velocity of
light and from there we get into the
notion this principle of relativity that
Albert Einstein is gonna pick up later
on and he's gonna talk about time
dilation and all sorts of nonsense that
came with special and general relativity
he develops his field equation but is it
1916 and it's gonna be this fellow
Hermann Minkowski and he's gonna come up
with a notion of space-time he said that
from now on you know you can't separate
time from space and space from time we
need three dimensions of space that we
need one dimension of time and so he
created this notion of space-time this
concept this concept which later on is
slowly gonna turn into a physical object
and again this is a major revolution at
least in mathematical physics okay why
is it well here you have the notion of
time dilation oh the twin paradox one of
the twin girls goes out comes back
thirty years later but one is four years
older than the other one and you wonder
how this could be how they can justify
this I mean they justify it with
equations but the question is how do you
justify this physically does this really
happen and this is where the problem is
the problem is whether mathematics is
the language of physics you can do your
calculation you can you know run your
equations figure them out is this gonna
is this gonna really be the case in the
physical world and this is what you got
to think about you know I mean I don't
know and then the question was you know
if Minkowski came up with space-time
what is this thing called space-time I
mean what's what is it good for what do
we use it for
and here are some notions this is one
notion of what a field might look like
the four-dimensional space-time field if
I mean this is the way they picture it
okay maybe this it kind of looks like
the ether except that instead of
particles you have all these this web of
sorts read I'm mentioning web so that's
one notion here's the other notion the
more popular one today and that's the
fishnet mass weighing down the fishnet
you wonder what the white stuff is that
serves as a background to the fishnet
and so they tell you well you're not
supposed to take the analogy literally
okay that's that's that's the argument
that space-time is what is it is it a
mathematical concept or is that a
physical concept what are we supposed to
do with it a physical object sorry what
are we supposed to do with this
space-time are we supposed to take it
literally are we supposed to laugh at it
or what is this space-time for I mean
here's what what you got explained and
and here's the explanation they use you
can see that this analogy so-called
analogy is used for something physical
here it is you see that the moon is
rolling around the earth around this
space hang like a ruler like the little
ball in a roulette and so it's this
space-time depression or the depression
in the fishnet which is a physical
interpretation okay they say this is a
physical interpretation and what is it a
physical interpretation for why the moon
doesn't fly out of the solar system okay
so so is this I'm not supposed to take
this literally then what is the point of
this analogy if I'm not supposed to take
it literally and so yeah we we get to
this point where were now we're doing
double talk here on the one hand they
say look you're supposed to take
space-time gives me prove there we've
done all kinds of experiments here are
the equations all that is so right no
you know argument you can't even argue
okay I don't want to hear about any
equation I want to know why the moon
doesn't
run out of the solar system that's all I
want to know here they're showing you
and they say well it's the depression in
space time in the moon rolls around
space time
okay so space time that means you're
saying that time has walked in this the
circular depression right the the edge
of this depression it's circular all
around anywhere you look at it or you
want elliptical find no problem the
question is here you have this this
depression and you're saying that's
what's preventing the moon from flying
away
I mean it's straight forward and then
the guy tells you well you're not
supposed to take it literally
what have we learned
I mean is it literal or not we we have
to take it literal I'm sorry because
that's your physical interpretation and
if it's not literal if you cannot take
it seriously and we should laugh it in
and discard it we have no purpose for
space-time anyway space-time has grown
over time to the point where it's just
become a monster especially that the
time portion of space-time right it's
that time portion that's driven people
nuts [ __ ] in mathematics because you
know since they do calculations and they
do equations they have to put that
little time in there for just about
everything and so time has become a
variable that a very important variable
you can't live without time in
mathematical physics okay that's the
issue and so I'm going to show you a few
celebrities right here okay that what
they have done with time what what the
notion what notions they have developed
with time and you tell me of these
people rational and these are all PhDs
that are going to show you some of them
are celebrities TV celebrities you've
probably seen some of them around or all
of them and you tell me if these guys
are rational I mean keep in mind these
guys have a PhD that means they went ten
years at least to the University they
wrote their a thesis or whatever and
this is what they learn this is what
they're telling you about time
physicists so-called physicists at math
man
you can call them physicists but these
people are gonna tell you what they
think about time and I just want you to
think about you know what they're saying
okay here's the first one and this is
gonna be Roger Penrose and he says that
time is out there like you know like an
individual an independent type of entity
okay let me get it set up here here goes
so there's relativity is extremely well
tested something like 14 decimals okay
places and decimal so we know that this
theory does describe the universe to an
extraordinarily precise degree so we
have to take it seriously okay that
theory tells us that we have to regard
space and time as one thing it's all out
there as one thing in the same sense as
spaces out there time is out there so
now he's saying that now the this Roger
Penrose is saying that this thing is out
there okay you're supposed to take it
seriously because first they proved it
okay proved it what with equations then
it says you got a three time as
something that's out there independently
like space supposedly is out there okay
so what do you think here's this guy
saying that time is out there what is
out there I mean you can say that a cow
is out there okay you can you know you
can say that's something that is
physical is out there how can you say
that a concept is out there what sense
does that make
and this this is the problem that we're
gonna see there to kind of treat time as
a physical object like objects like
saying oh yeah there's this thing this
ocean this medium called time we're
going through time we've got a trouble
even time we live in time so so they're
tired about a can they're talking about
some kind of medium in which we inhabit
called time okay and this could be the
fourth leg of space and keep in mind
okay so here you talk about a guy you
know PhD not only a PhD is a famous PhD
Robert Roger Penrose and this guy is
Billy
he believes that there's a physical or
some entity or some medium out there
called time this and these are the guys
that are influencing the majority of
people out there on the streets can I
keep that in mind here's another one and
this is Stephen Hawking let me get him
set up and he's gonna talk about you got
to talk about negative time you know
wonder about these people sometimes
there goes says if there's one thing
that he's questioned by this father what
would he like to be remembered for
and he says imaginary time people think
it's something you have in dreams or
when you you're up against a deadline
but it's a well-defined concept but it's
a imaginary time is like another
direction in space it's the one bit of
work science fiction writers haven't
used because they don't understand it
no kidding I mean I don't blame them for
not understanding I mean do you
understand this imaginary time I thought
all time was imaginary you know we've
got the negative time imaginary time
what is all this nonsense well what do
we need all this for it's just to
explain how the universe works imaginary
time and you might say well you know
it's a mathematical concept yeah he puts
it in his book in his brief history of
time use it he talks about imaginary
time in there worthless garbage nonsense
absolute nonsense really for people who
lightly deal with physics very very
tangentially very superficially oh okay
imaginary time what a great concept we
don't need this nonsense this has
nothing to do with physics or science
okay so yeah and this guy invented
imaginary time so that was one of his
pet peeves okay here's another fella
this one just blew my mind he's a
professor at Berkeley
and this is what he says let me put it
in God yes
space and time are likely linked in
general relativity but if you create
more space you're creating more time if
the expansion of the universe starting
with a Big Bang is constantly creating
more space it must also be creating new
time and the newly created space is the
space between the galaxies and the newly
created time is what we call now if this
theory is right then we need a possible
real test where we are creating new
space now there is this guy he's uh this
is Richard Muller he's a professor of
Berkeley again and this guy says that as
you create space you create more time so
okay so there's more distance between
the galaxies and that's the so called
space expansion fine okay well let's
accept let's concede that what does that
have to do with time and he says well
you know if space-time is expanding
sound only space but time is also expand
you're creating more time that's his
so-called theory okay has gotten you
know it's just unbelievable and neither
neither are we creating more space in
either time but that's what these people
believe and these again these are these
are professional PhDs you know they're
teachers they're they're professors
they're teaching the new generation of
people and they're the ones who get
access to the microphones to talk to the
average person out there and what are
they saying they're saying that you know
you're creating more space you create
more time what is that what can that
possibly mean and then when you say we
mean you're creating time yeah it's it's
the now the now is expanding see they
keep treating time as a physical object
all these folks they treat it as a some
kind of medium out there they don't know
what it is they can't define it they
never have they said nobody knows what
time is but they're all experts at it
and they say oh yeah we're creating more
space therefore we create more time
then we have imaginary time and time is
something that's out there you know
running around by itself like
independent of us or maybe dependent on
us right because you know they're saying
that you know every every observer has
his own notion of time his own reference
frame so it's like your time is not my
time so we don't know what time is right
but boy do we talk about times almost
like extinction we don't know what
extinctions like or how to explain it
but everybody's got into a theory about
extinction no doubt there okay okay
here's another fellow see if I can get
this is Jim khalili and you know he's a
British guy who does quite a few
documentaries you can find them on
YouTube just about everywhere and this
guy's gonna say something that will blow
the minds of a lot of people out there
he says you don't have any free will you
don't have any free will because because
we have a blocked universe okay
the future has already happened and it's
one of my arguments in my book where I
say that you know if that's the case you
know if the future is already there and
God already knows what's gonna happen
you know he knows it all then what what
does that mean it means that you're just
a cartoon character it's like you know
Bugs Bunny does Bugs Bunny have free
will no Bugs Bunny typically has the
will that the cartoonist put it into the
little picture okay so Bugs Bunny
doesn't have any free will in the same
way you don't have any free will if if
they if there is a block universe and
here you see what he says let me put it
up there in a second here there we go
says if you take this block of
four-dimensional space-time literally it
means you have no to abandon free will
this is a PhD talking okay it means not
only is the future preordained but it's
already there it's already happened so
we're talking about the past not the
future yeah
so what do you think you have any free
will do you think you you have any free
will or do you think it's already been
preordained by whoever god whatever I
mean these are these are PhDs and
they're putting God into the picture in
subtle ways they're saying yeah the
futures already happened so who defined
the future who who made me do what I do
I mean or what a planning undo is there
someone who's guiding me or do I really
think I have free will and I really
don't because the block universe that
these people are talking about already
exists already is they're all we're
doing is walking on footsteps this is is
this the case is there a file cabinet
out there God's file cabinet where all I
need to do is pull you if I could access
it right I'll pull the file out for a
bill Goethe I don't know in the year
2030 if we make it that far I pulled the
file here I can read when I'm gonna be
doing what I'm gonna be thinking every
little second every microsecond every
moosh motion I do with my little finger
all that stuff is already in there that
must be some computer just for one
person let alone for all of humanity
but these people believe in this stuff
and this stuff these are these are
religious notions that have been around
for centuries by the way you know they
were discussed by st. Thomas and st.
Augustine you know hundreds of years ago
and these people are reviving the same
exact concepts and now under the
so-called you know scientific context
right and they're saying oh no but now
we're applying science to this and what
are they saying where they're saying the
same thing that st. Augustine you said
you know it's like you know it's already
preordained and you've got no choice you
you know no free will
ok so if you thought you had free will
wrong if you kill someone tomorrow hey
just say Hague sorry judge you know God
made me do it or the devil made me do it
whoever I had no choice in the matter
because it was already preordained my
god okay here's another fellow and I
think a lot of you know him and he's
Brian Greene and he talks about the
reverse time the arrow of time going
backwards and reconstructing cups that
have broken on the floor unbelievable
but here is let me see if I put them up
here give me a second there it goes why
don't we ever see events unfolding in
reverse order arrow goes back to the
shooter according to the laws of physics
this can happen now how's that for a
magic trick okay the arrow goes back yay
to the archer and then the the glass of
word reassembles itself and goes back
Hollywood can do anything really the
question is he says these are the laws
of physics is this physics or is this
just a bunch of nonsense idiocy from
Harvard and Cambridge I mean if you
really believe this nonsense you got a
screw loose and if these people have
PhDs and this is what they've come up
with this what they peddle out there we
got to start wondering about their state
of mind let alone whether they're really
physicists and whether mathematics is
the language of physics this should make
you stop and think if you know that
should be a slap in the face to wake you
up you know I mean come on okay and he
has a couple more we can get him up here
this is another fellow who's coming up
on the ranks okay after Carl Sagan and
Brian Greene well this one is probably
the new generation name is Sean Carroll
and what he says I mean he's an expert
right says the universe will expand
forever
you have this space-time right and it's
expanding right it's expanding expanding
expanding and you say well is there a
moment where a little stop I mean if
these people believe that 14 billion
years ago right the universe had an
origin from nothing energy what a god
whatever we don't care right it had an
origin why would it continue forever you
would think it begins and ends right but
they say no it had a beginning but has
no end this is their this is what they
came up with and here's a shot Carol
saying it let me get him up there said
the universe will expand forever back
when I was your age we didn't know what
the universe was going to do today some
people thought the universe was going to
wreak elapsed but if there's dark energy
and dark energy does not go away the
universe is going to keep expanding
forever and ever and ever
14 billion years in the past but an
infinite number of years into the future
now how's that for a prediction right
nobody can you know contradict them I
mean because you know I can say anything
I can talk about angels and the angels
will carry me to heaven when I die well
you gotta wait until I die right now in
my case maybe you can figure out if
angels that carry me to heaven but when
I give you a prediction for the year
3000 you know that's a loose cannon
that's what I mean
well what are you gonna do is say no
you're wrong let me go to the future
find out if if it really happened you
know so these people have that notion
and one of the ideas behind that the
reason they come up with this is this
one here they was they had this W map
project and which involves satellites
and measurements and so on and they
prove that the universe is flat you can
see it it looks like a board yeah
and you're saying I made this up no no
this was an astronomy magazine I showed
this couple of weeks ago this this was
an astronomy magazine this this take
publish they have room for this
editorial space for this nonsense for
this junk you want to print something
saying that relativity is bunk
they won't let you print it because it's
their club and their magazine right so
they can print whatever they want and
then stuff they print they say well this
is this is important for the public to
know that the universe is flat like a
washboard you know those ancient
washboards or the this is the universe
accordion is people flat universe
astronomy magazine 1999 so here all
these people have these weird notions we
have negative time we have imaginary
time we have time dilation we have time
as one at the fourth leg of religion
called space-time you know what are we
supposed to think of this have they made
a monster out of time is this what we're
supposed to conclude or is this real you
know I would think that all these people
have lost it they're floating in the air
they no longer have their feet on the
ground I can't even take them seriously
and yeah since they run the show you
know you're not allowed to print stuff
against them in their own magazines and
guess what they end up proving their
foregone conclusions they say oh here we
had like Mumtaz was gravity probe a
gravity probe a you know they were able
to measure how far up to put the
satellites essentially that was that
there was a precursor to gravity probe B
which later said you know what did that
prove prove that we dragged space around
and you say well hold that let me
criticize that no they won't allow you
to they've already proven it it's you
who has to memorize what they've proven
and that's what they pass on to the new
generation what happens a person goes to
college and he starts
if there's two types of people there's
those people who say well this is all
nonsense well that guy doesn't make it
past the course or he drops out or he
changes career he said I'm gonna become
an engineer or lawyer or whatever and
the guys who stay onboard are the guys
who suck up are the guys who are gonna
go up there and say oh yeah space-time
yeah black holes yeah big bang you know
so they'll just repeat the the catechism
they get jobs you get good positions
because you know they they were able to
bow down and these are choir boys yes
men and so now these people get put into
you important places good salaries and
they perpetuate the religion and so we
have this body of so-called physicist
mathematical physicists and they have
all these big positions in colleges in
centers like you know NASA or or CERN
you know accelerators and so on and
these are the people that go to those
places the people who sucked up the
people who pass the test the people who
wrote a thesis that their supervisor
approved okay and so you know what we've
done is we created a system where we
could where we perpetuate these ideas
and then you can't fight these ideas
because you're not allowed to publish in
their magazines right or if you do maybe
you know I was able to publish a couple
things out there but it's like you know
Loki it's like nobody pays attention to
you because you didn't you didn't come
up with a new equation or something and
what you're trying to do is criticize
the physical interpretations and they
don't care about physical
interpretations anymore all they care
about is being able to you know to do
their math their equations play around
with those variables and then you know
they become famous and some reporters
say hey you know we'd like to interview
you for a documentary they're not gonna
go to me or someone else that no one
knows know they're gonna go to these
guys and they bring them on board these
these people are able to tell the public
now their physical interpretation
without any criticism and they can say
whatever they want they can say look
space-time is warped it's for it why
can't we imagine it well it's for
dimension we can't imagine
four-dimensional things we can only
imagine three-dimensional things or
lesser you know two-dimensional woods
and so they get away with all kinds of
nonsense all kinds of arguments and you
can't put them against the wall and even
if you know ya like me goes on board and
starts criticizing them they would say
hey you know how many people do you have
behind you look at all the ones we have
behind us so it's a voting thing it's
like we're majority and we run the show
and so there's no way to approach the
problem right now we've painted
ourselves into a corner as humans right
we've painted ourselves into a corner
because now we're not able to challenge
any of these theories anymore okay the
only way you're gonna be able to
challenge them is printing through a
magazine that they control and the only
way you're gonna be allowed to publish
there is if you put some kind of
equation they don't want physical
interpretations physical interpretations
is a prerogative of the guy who made it
to the top within that you know that
Club and he's able to tell the public
his physical interpretation and he's
gonna say some nonsense people say hold
it but that sounds like idiocy like
poppycock and a guy said yeah but it's
what the equations show and we proved it
with such a such experiment which again
is a physical interpretation of theirs
and and you know when you start trying
to criticize them you'll never get to be
able to publish something to criticize
what the guy said so they get away with
murder they can say whatever they want
these days and there's no way to
challenge it anyways time has become a
monster especially in the 20th century
beginning of the 21st we're not gonna be
able to roll time back it space time
this religion that includes black holes
dark matter dark energy Big Bang all
that show all those parts of that show
they're integral part of space-time
we're not we're not gonna be able to
erase any of that anymore and so it's
become a religion now it's it's just
belief it's just the prayed of
space/time prayed or the black hole you
know they even take pictures of
so-called black hole you're supposed to
accept it on the basis of their
testimony alone they say yeah we took
this picture of all this matter rushing
into a black hole well for all I know it
could be angels but they tell you it's a
black hole you got to believe it what
are you gonna do now how are you gonna
challenge that on a rational basis say
well tell me what a black hole is no
then you they'll never tell you that
they'll say well we don't really know
what a black hole is or like I put in
one of my videos they asked it a lot of
these guys Michiyo kaku and some of the
others and asked um what is a black hole
made of and they all drew a blank you
know I don't know what is a black hole
made oh I don't know what's made out of
mass right what is mass it's nonsense
it's mathematical nonsense
and so on so we have this religion and
right now you have two choices you
either go against it or you fall in
start praying to space-time and Einstein
and all these other gurus that have
popped up and making thousands if not
millions of dollars by spreading
nonsense okay starting Wednesday I'm
gonna start criticizing some of these
folks one by one
let's see what these guys have to offer
to science not only not only for
relativity space-time black holes dark
matter all that stuff now also the
quantum guys because they also have
irrational theories you're not allowed
to question their physical
interpretations because they themselves
say it's irrational we don't understand
it but that's that's it we proven it so
they prove it but they don't understand
it so what did they prove I don't know
so I'm gonna be attacking some of these
celebrities out there that make lots of
money and come up with nonsense
specially physical interpretations
the reason they can get away with the
reason they ended up with that right
that they cannot answer the questions is
because they don't use objects see if
you're gonna give a physical
interpretation to the universe to the
workings of the universe which is I
guess what physics was all about or was
supposed to be about right we're
supposed to know how mother nature runs
her shop and the only way we're gonna
figure that out is by making the
invisible visible you're gonna have to
go out there and say what does Mother
Nature used to do gravity what does
mother need to use to do light and you
might say well she doesn't use anything
because I can't see it or I can't touch
it well then in effect you're putting
spirits in that same space
you're saying that gravity is done with
spirits because you know if a ball falls
to the floor something came in contact
with the skin of the ball and I don't
know how I'll still for - to make you
understand that if you don't understand
you're an irrational individual
something had to come in contact with
the skin of the ball and all you got to
do is identify that invisible intangible
something this isn't what these people
do but these people do and say hey you
know we can do this with mass we can do
it with energy we can do a force field
with all these concepts but you can't
use a concept as a physical object and
this is where the problem is and so I'm
going to be criticizing some of these
people in the next few weeks and show
you what what they're saying to see if
it sounds rational to you there are
physical interpretations and I think you
know you're gonna conclude that they are
irrational individuals and you wonder
how they ever got a degree